the pre-trial hearing is scheduled to
take place in a couple of weeks in the
case of a Florida woman accused of
trapping her boyfriend inside of a
suitcase and filming him crying out for
help Sarah Boone is charged with
second-degree murder in the death of
Jorge Torres Jr three years ago Boone
told investigators that she and Torres
were drinking wine at home while playing
a game of hide and seek Boone said she
eventually passed out in bed but when
she woke up she checked a suitcase that
Torres was reportedly hiding in and
found him unresponsive but during the
investigation police found videos on
Boone's phone recording Torres as he
tried to escape the suitcase Boone's
defense attorney said he'll present a
battered spouse defense at trial there
were reports of intimate partner
violence between the two Boone's next
court date for that pre-trial hearing is
scheduled for March 28th and to kind of
give you an idea of evidence that we
expect to see here's Boone's 911 phone
call from the day in question
now tell me exactly what happened there
my boyfriend already were playing last
night and
um
we were playing and like kind of a hide
and seek kind of thing so
I fell asleep and I woke up and he was
dead in the suitcase so I don't know
what happened
I don't know what happens like he has
like blood coming out of his mouth and I
don't know if like he had like an
aneurysm of what happened right okay all
right okay listen we're getting here
okay he'd be hanging from somewhere or
what man no I pulled him out of the
suitcase I tried giving him CPR
okay so he was in a suitcase yes and I
fell asleep
okay how old is the how old is the
boyfriend remember 42 year old man all
right listen to me okay
I understand I just need to confirm this
is he an easy awake or not is he
conscious at all no be purple right you
see breathing no
Boone said in her interrogation that
Torres JR could have gotten out of the
suitcase at any point but investigators
challenged that claim
you they didn't remember this when you
told us last night that he was laughing
you were laughing you put him in the
suitcase he has two fingers sticking out
and you go to bed now we see something
totally different and it actually shows
you upset and again using uh
derogatory terms to him when he's
begging for his legs to get out of that
suitcase so so we're assuming we're not
assuming so it just happened to be that
whenever I was videotaping or doing
whatever else it was had just happened
to not have that in it okay
and you also in the video you can't see
any holes there's nowhere in that where
the zipper separates and you can see a
hole if there's a hole he's pushing on
it begging you to get out
we should probably see that
that hole is actually what I've been
able to get out alcohol based off what
you're telling us he should have been
able to get out but the video
shows him attempting to get out begging
to get out and he can't so that's that's
just what we're trying to figure out I
don't know if maybe you had too much to
drink you zipped it up all the way and
then you know I did not tip it up all
the way
okay well Brian you must have argued you
know battered spouse defense or syndrome
before how do you think that's going to
work here yeah so I have Jesse in the
cases that I've prepped for and also
I've seen it's a very different scenario
than in this case it's the wife sleeping
next to the husband who's abusing her
for decades years whatever you want to
say and then turns around and stabs him
in his sleep because that's the only
opportunity that she has the idea is
it's PTSD and that this partner
oftentimes a woman is in such a hell
that that slight moment where they can
get away they use violence as a form of
almost self-defense but trapping in a
suitcase recording and laughing mocking
well those facts are I think where the
defense fails in trying to raise this uh
this issue of ipv yeah Terry so we chose
not to play the audio of Taurus trying
to get out of the suitcase because it's
just incredibly disturbing but the jury
is probably going to see it during a
trial how do you think that's going to
impact them oh it's going to really
impact that jury and I think it's going
to have an impact act on the ultimate
verdict here I had a chance to see that
video I wish I had not seen it you
cannot unsee something like that and
listen to his voice as he's begging her
Sarah please open the suitcase I cannot
breathe and I think if the jury sees
that they're going to understand this
was not an accident she was not drunk
she was videotaping him begging for his
life and so I definitely think that it's
something that should get into evidence
there should be no problem getting this
in it's an admission of sorts and of
course I think if that jury hears the
begging and the pleading for Life
they're going to turn and think this
woman is guilty and she should go to
jail for the rest of her life really
disturbing case I know it presents kind
of an interesting legal question a legal
defense but from right now doesn't seem
like it has much weight three men
accused of gunning down an up-and-coming
rapper are still on the brink of finding
out their Fates the jury in the
xxxtentacion murder trial has now
deliberated for more than 12 hours XX
text tentacion's real name was Jose
onfroy in 2018 he was robbed and shot to
death while leaving a motorcycle
dealership prosecutors presented a
really lengthy case pointing the finger
at Michael Boatright as the trigger man
Trayvon Newsom is the second gunman and
Diedrich Williams is the ringleader and
getaway driver now the star witness was
another co-defendant Robert Allen who
pleaded guilty to second-degree murder
and robbery charges with a possibly
reduced sentence up for grabs he
testified against his alleged
accomplices while also detailing his
role in the crime only one defense team
actually presented a case Michael
boatright's attorney Joseph Kima called
a Broward County sergeant and detective
to poke holes in the investigation on
Monday the jury wanted to review text
messages that were connected to the
defendants now the court couldn't give
them access to everything on the phones
due to privacy issues but instead went
through nearly 1 000 messages on a
screen the jury is going to continue
those deliberations on Tuesday time to
bring in my co-host legal analyst to
give us some insight here defensive
attorney Brian buckmeyer former trial
Attorney Terry Austin it's good to have
you both here Terry so far jury
relatively quiet they did have that one
question about Dietrich Williams does it
give you any insight into their
deliberations right now I don't
understand what is taking them so long
the evidence was clear with the videos
and of course they had the cooperating
witness Alan who testified as to what
each of their role was but when they
start asking about what the role was of
one individual it leads me to believe
that perhaps they think not everyone is
as culpable and so perhaps they are
thinking that as the driver he was not
as you know guilty as the rest but we
all know if you're in the scene and you
are there when the crime is being
committed you're going to be charged and
chances are you're also going to be
convicted so maybe they're dying to
separate the roles Brian let's play out
a scenario here could the jury come back
with verdicts maybe one defendant at a
time or do they have to decide all three
before coming back Jesse I think that's
what's is causing the issue here that
they're looking at each and every
individual defendant as Terry is
pointing out and I think that they're
trying to come out with a verdict for
all three at once but when they maybe
decide on one defendant then that pulls
into question how much do the other
defendant actually participate in
um yes is the idea of in for a penny in
for a pound if you're there you're all
convicted but you can't just merely be
present at the scene of a crime to be
convicted of the charges so I think the
jury is fighting over okay how much
should this person do how much should
that person do and then trying to
present all at once and that's why we're
getting a delay we will wait and see we
will wait and see when the jury comes
back crazy it's a longer deliberation
than the Alec Murdoch trial and we
promise to keep you updated on the case
of Paul Flores the California Man
convicted of killing Kristen smart
almost 30 years ago the judge officially
sentenced Flores to 25 years to life in
prison calling him quote a cancer to
society 19 year old Kristen smart
vanished in 1996 while attending
California Polytechnic State University
she was officially declared dead in
2002. prosecutors said that Flores was
the last person to see smart alive and
either raped her or tried to do so
before killing her in his dorm room in
2021 investigators used ground
penetrating radar on flores's property
to uncover items that were connected to
the case in October Flores was convicted
of Smart's murder while his father who
prosecutors accused of helping hide
Smart's body was acquitted of being an
accessory to the crime after 26 years
Smart's body has never been found